doctor strange might be able to control
time but can benedict cumberbatch lift
weights how much pain did the english
actor have to go through for that
shirtless scene in dr strange here's how
benedict's cumberbatch got ripped to
play dr strange
every actor has different methods of
preparing and training for a role and
benedict cumberbatch focused on his
physical transformation as he got ready
for his superhero debut as dr steven
strange in 2016 and again for doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness a
leaked photo of cumberbatch training
revealed that one way the actor has been
getting his body in superhero shape is
weightlifting according to a breakdown
of cumberbatch's fitness routine from
superhero jacked the actor would have
been hitting the weights at least three
times a week to see this kind of
progress pumping iron was also a key
component of cumberbatch's training for
the 2016 doctor strange film he later
revealed that kevin feige told him it
was actually one of the toughest fitness
regimens that marvel studios has ever
put an actor through per the sun with
that said he seems to have been hitting
the weights even harder for the sequel
of course weightlifting isn't the only
thing benedict cumberbatch did to get
ripped for doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness the actor also
regularly practiced yoga one of his
favorite forms of exercise to help him
get ready for the role this is something
that has stuck with him ever since he
went to teach english in a tibetan
buddhist monastery as a teenager there
he experienced the amazing power of the
mind per bbc
open your eyes
alongside strengthening the mind yoga is
great for the core which helped
cumberbatch with his wire work on the
set of doctor strange even though the
actor had a stunned double he still
spent plenty of time moving around on a
wire in fact according to the actor
himself stephen broussard and kevin
feige said i've done more while work on
this than any other film they've worked
on cumberbatch continued to say i get
flung through a wall or suspended by a
wire over a drop and then smashed into
an asteroid in another dimension flung
off the edge of a building that's
changing shape or knocked over a balcony
or smashed through a cabinet but it's
not as bad as it might sound as
cumberbatch quipped
you can't really say you're a superhero
unless you've actually experienced some
of the physical trauma cumberbatch has
continued practicing yoga and with the
multiverse expanding having a strong
core is essential
it's true what they say you can't out
train a bad diet that's why benedict
cumberbatch makes sure to watch what he
eats for the 2016 doctor strange film
cumberbatch told e that the diet was
very strict for months before production
this strict regimen continued during the
entirety of his training and throughout
filming too while talking to timeout
cumberbatch revealed that he eats a
plant-based diet and added i would say
that i'm vegan but not everything i wear
is vegan benedict cumberbatch isn't the
only marvel actor who's gotten into
superhero shape as a vegan his co-stars
chris hemsworth and scarlett johansson
both adopted plant-based diets or
training for the 2012 avengers film
cumberbatch has continued on the
plant-based roots the actor also
incorporated quite a bit of strength
training into his workout schedule as
explained by the american heart
association strength training is a
combination of simple weight-bearing
exercises that use free weights machines
or your body's own resistance these
exercises can be done as a solo workout
or in conjunction with cardio and weight
training as cumberbatch did according to
superhero jacks to have consolidated the
mcu stars workout regimen cumberbatch
would need to be working out a minimum
of three to five times a week to achieve
a superhero bud on at least three of
these five days he would do extensive
strength training
along with weightlifting yoga and
strength training benedict cumberbatch's
workout routine also includes plenty of
cardiovascular exercise cumberbatch is a
longtime fan of cardio activities like
running which he has been doing for
years to keep fit however he needed to
increase the intensity of his cardio
while training for the mcu so he decided
to incorporate interval sprints
according to superhero jacks his typical
20-minute interval sprint exercise would
be split into two sessions for the first
he would walk for two minutes then
sprint for one then halfway through he
would cut down his walk time to one
minute and run one then walk one for the
remaining session cumberbatch also went
through months of physical training to
learn how to fight and move properly on
the set of doctor strange most of this
combat and martial arts training took
place alongside his stunt double george
kirby and his co-star mass mickelson
with cumberbatch taking his workout
routine up a few notches since 2016
there's little doubt the actors been
putting in a few days of high intensity
cardio each week to get ripped for the
sequel
benedict cumberbatch eats pretty
healthily all year while filming the bbc
detective drama sherlock cumberbatch
kept himself in very good shape by
eating very sensibly that's his co-star
rupert graves told the daily mail the
actor continued to say he only eats
bananas hummus vegetables and nuts and
then he has a special lunch brought in
however cumberbatch's diet had to change
when he started training for the 2016
superhero film with all the exercise he
was doing he had to increase his calorie
intake given how much cumberbatch has
stepped up his physical training for
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness it only makes sense that he has
also upped his calorie intake again as
reported by men's health the average
recommended calorie intake for a man
ranges from about 1 800 and 2
300 per day if cumberbatch had to double
his intake he would have been eating
anywhere between 3600
and four thousand six hundred calories
per day just shy of chris hemsworth's
five thousand calorie thought diet
benedict cumberbatch has never been a
big drinker he's often commented on how
the portrayal of alcohol and drug
consumption has been glamorized on
screen but he's never been enticed
himself the actor and father of three
described himself to radio times as nia
sober even at the end of a long day the
thought of having a drink doesn't appeal
to him with that thing of having a glass
of wine when the kids have gone to bed
i'm like i'm quite tired and i don't
really fancy that glass of sugary
alcohol ditching the booze has
undoubtedly helped cumberbatch gain
muscle tone while he's been training for
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness benedict cumberbatch
inadvertently created the shakespeare
diet while he was filming doctor strange
and performing hamlet at the same time
he later told entertainment weekly it
was the bedrock of keeping me healthy
and sane during that time he had a bitty
few months while he balanced a starring
role in a marvel superhero film and a
performance at a popular shakespeare
production he started out by doing an
hour of training in the morning
rehearsing hamlet for the rest of the
day and then trying to get home in time
to put his newborn son to bed when the
curtain for hamlet opened cumberbatch
only got busier he would still train in
the morning followed by rehearsals for
doctor strange and then his hamlet
performance at the end of the day hamlet
was like a three hour cardiovascular
workout i don't think i was in better
shape during the film than i was when i
was doing hamlet and training for the
film cumberbatch seems to have
implemented the shakespeare diet 2.0
while training for dr strange in the
multiverse of madness by repeating and
adapting the process for the marvel
sequel while he wasn't performing a
shakespeare play cumberbatch also had a
small cameo in the bubble and had to fit
his training around that second project
benedict cumberbatch's training for the
2016 doctor strange movie started long
before filming officially began that's
because cumberbatch understood what it
was really going to take to play a
superhero you have to be incredibly fit
i mean i started working out for this
film not just to fill the suit so to
speak but also just to be able to take
knocks cumberbatch didn't just train for
the bare minimum either he also enjoyed
being hands-on and doing his own stunts
whenever possible director scott
derrickson wrote on twitter i was very
fortunate that benedict was so good at
doing his own stunts and fight sequences
benedict did all the action and stunts
that was safe for him to do however the
action sequences were a lot of work and
took a physical toll which is why it was
so important for him to build up his
strength and train hard since
cumberbatch has bulked up more than ever
for his role in multiverse of madness
it's likely he needed to be ready for
even bigger fight scenes in the sequel
as the old proverb goes slow and steady
wins the race that's advice that
benedict's cumberbatch took to heart
while filming doctor strange he didn't
transform his body overnight he did it
all over a long period of time in a
healthy way rather than overloading
himself cumberbatch is apparently all
about healthy choices rather than
unhealthy shortcuts he told
entertainment weekly in 2016 you can do
a bodybuilding thing where you're
destroying your body to rip new muscle
or you can do it the way i did it which
is quite diligently over a long period
of time with a healthy diet exercise and
diet go hand in hand when it comes to
body transformation and cumberbatch made
sure he was packing on the pounds the
right way too however cumberbatch had an
even harder job bulking up for doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
than he did for the first superhero film
because he had just lost 21 pounds for
his role in the courier while
cumberbatch told cinema blend it was all
done in a healthy way he said it was a
horrible and vulnerable experience
it's fair to say that cumberbatch isn't
flying solo while making any big
physical changes for a role
transformations like this become a much
easier process when you have a whole
team of people whose job it is to
specifically monitor an actor's diet and
exercise alongside working out with a
personal trainer is stunt double george
kirby and his cast mates cumberbatch
also had someone keeping an eye on his
diet moreover he doesn't personally have
to worry about his calorie intake or
expenditure or drawing up the perfect
workout plan so he can hit all his
muscle groups in the gym as he puts it
while talking to entertainment weekly
it's all handed to you it's not that
hard you just really have to apply
yourself he admitted he's been lucky to
have this kind of support saying quote
people would kill for that kind of
experience
for the majority of his role in the 2016
doctor strange film benedict's
cumberbatch is covered by robes and the
cloak of levitation so while his
training no doubt helped him with stuns
and physical exertion his months of
exercising and eating right came down to
just 24 hours the night before and the
day of his shirt-off moment per the late
late show with james corden the day and
night before you kind of dehydrate
yourself and then on the actual day on
set i don't even know if i should be
saying this you basically are told to
eat skittles and drink coffee why do you
do this because it dehydrates you it's
horrible so basically your skin then
shrink wraps around the muscle fiber
seems like a difficult experience to go
through for a single shot
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]